come here said his father Patrick step
closer should I pick you up by the years
now you shouted Patrick who was the sort
of game they played his father reached
out in class Patrick's years between his
four fingers and thumbs Patrick put his
hands around his father's wrists and his
father pretended to pick him up by the
years but Patrick really took the strain
with his arms his father stood up and
lifted Patrick until their eyes were
level let go with your hands he said no
shouted Patrick let go and I'll drop it
at the same time said his father
persuasively Patrick released his
father's wrist but his father continued
to pinch his ears for a moment the whole
weight of his body was supported by his
ears he quickly caught his father's
wrists again I would she said you said
you were going to drop me please let go
of my ears
his father still held him dangling in
the air you've learned something very
useful today said always think for
yourself
never let other people make important
decisions for you please let go said
Patrick please he felt that he was going
to cry but he pushed back his sense of
desperation his arms were exhausted but
if he relaxed them he felt as if his
ears were going to be torn off like the
gold foil from a pot of cream just
ripped or from the side of his head you
said he yelled you said his father
dropped and don't whimper he said in a
bored voice it's very unattractive
he sat down at the piano and started
playing the March again
but Patrick did not dance he ran from
the room through the hall out of the
kitchen over the terrace along the olive
grove and into the Pinewood he found the
thorn bush ducked underneath it and slid
down a small slope into his most secret
hiding place under a canopy of bushes
wedged up against a pine tree which was
surrounded by thickets on every side he
sat down and tried to stop the sobs like
hiccups that snarled his throat why did
his father do that nobody should do that
to anybody else he thought in winter
when there was ice on the puddles you
could see the bubbles trapped underneath
and the air couldn't breathe it had been
ducked by the ice and held under and he
hated that because he was so unfair and
so you always smashed the ice to let the
air go free nobody can find me here he
thought and then he thought what if
nobody can find me here I I think it's I
hope it's very clear i he he first of
all triumph in the idea of being in a
secure hiding place right and then in a
deeper sense he feels that no one will
ever really understand right his
experience right so the it's really only
you know it's delightful to hide if you
think you're going to be far but if you
think you're never going to be found and
never recognized it's actually a fresh
source of anguish mmm beyond the initial
anguish which things you want to hide
mmm so he he falls you know falls
through the full security of having fun
somewhere died yes I mean the
homelessness is very literal in this in
this novel in that it's it's about the
loss of this house at one level
and that has been a kind of massive
consolation for Patrick and during
during his childhood he's he's sort of
populated the the all his surroundings
with magical thinking he feels when he's
raped by his father that a gecko has has
taken some custody of some essential
part of him and and run away and saved
him from being utterly destroyed he has
all these secret hiding places the whole
landscape has been made magical and he
gets from his surroundings and from the
animals around him the kind of comfort
or a substitute for the kind of comfort
that children would normally get from
their parents if their parents were was
civilized and that's to some extent the
the subject after the house has been
lost I don't want to give anything away
but in the fourth book which you may not
have read the house gets lost and when
the fifth book he's reflecting on what
it's meant to him and this is just one
paragraph looking back towards the end
on the property where he was hiding and
investing so much emotion when he was a
child Ella knows his mother Eleanor had
given so Nizar away but at least she had
provided it in the first place if only
as a massive substitute for herself a
mother land that was there to cover for
her in capacities in a sense its
loveliness was a decoy the branches of
almond blossoms reaching into the
cloudless sky the unopened irises like
paintbrushes dipped in blue the clear
amber resin bleeding from the gunmetal
bark of the cherry
trees all that was a decoy he must stop
thinking about him
a child's need for protection would have
assembled a system out of whatever
materials came to Han have a ritual or
bizarre he might have been a spider in a
broom cupboard or the appearance of a
neighbor across the well in a block of
flats or the number of red cars between
the front door and the school gates that
took on the burden of love and
reassurance in his case it had been a
hillside in France his home had
stretched from the dark pine wood at the
top of the slope all the way to the pale
bamboo that grew besides the stream at
its foot in between were terraces where
vine shoots burst from twisted stumps
that spent the winter looking like
rusted iron and olive trees rushed from
green to gray and gray to green in the
combing wind halfway down the slope
where the cluster was the cluster of
houses and cypresses and the network of
pools where he'd experienced the most
horror and negotiated the most far
French reprieves even the steep
mountainside opposite the house was
colonized by his imagination and not
only with the army of trees marching
across its crest later on its rejection
of human encroachment became an image of
his own less reliable aloofness
and that definitely introduces that
constant theme of the duality by wit by
way of which sign as there is the scene
in which something horrible takes place
is traumatic place at the same time it's
this match magical sanctuary and true
mother land a homeland of for Patrick
but on that theme of people will
fetishize whatever they have to hand as
he says yes absolutely had it been some
suburb in northern England yet would
have been it probably and a lot of the
these books are about about substitution
about the way that people substitute one
thing for another and then substitute
something for for the thing they
initially substituted right all his his
addiction and the whole story is a story
of of substitute Ori consolations
Patrick manages not to pass on that
chain of endless substitutions to his
sons
yes he's obsessed with with the the flow
of poison from generation to generation
and and he there are the two obvious
things that that people do with our
children he manages to to avoid name
need you know doing your children what
you hated having done to you or or doing
the opposite of what you hated having
done to you you know hysterically
lurching to the other side of the boned
and capsizing and in another direction
but he knows that he can't that at the
more subtle level of of the effect that
his upbringing his had on him his
conditioning as hard on him so - it's
very difficult to not to affect your
children with the consequences in your
own conditioning
however aware you become in the end
you're you're communicating your your
way of being not only do they not do
what you tell them to
and did they not they also don't do what
you do to some extent but they they do
what you are and that is very very
difficult to to overcome that's an
ongoing task I think for any parent
absolutely I mean absolutely
wouldn't you say there's difference
though between Robert and and Thomas in
that regard Robert seems to take it upon
himself in particular there is some
resonance in in the in the consciousness
of Robert it's extremely sensitive to
his father's moods Bruce Thomas is
described as being slightly more
autonomous in terms of being his own his
own D as a person absolutely Tom
Thomas's is is born late enough and as
as being sort of adored as by Mary as
the last child who's able to have and he
doesn't he doesn't really buy into his
father's unconscious which is what
Robert is doing Robert his you know
identifying with his father's sense of
loss identifying with his father's sense
of betrayal turning against his
grandmother it's all of that all the
Robert takes it upon himself to
perpetuate and and Patrick feels this
terrible conflict on the one hand his
brother pleased to have converted Robert
to have got him on his side and on the
other hand he sees it as a disaster
because Robert has been you know in
infected by this by this sense of loss
but in a in some ways Robert sense of
loss is ordinary you know he hasn't he
loves son either because it's a
beautiful and fascinating place he
hasn't got he hasn't fetishized it he
just loves it to say it's a different
relation but to Patrick the one whose
truck in trouble because he's fertilized
it and loved it and hated it so it's
incredibly complicated and he feels he's
going to lose his
sanity by losing this gigantic it's like
what Winnicott used you know called a
transitional object like a blanket
little children have him as a substitute
for their mother
well this property is his transitional
object that he's never let go of right
and he's got to let go of it at 45 which
some people says a bit later discussion
and then when when you reach that point
when is the appropriate 10 Ribeiro
blanket yeah but but it's performing
that role but it's appeasing a gigantic
anxiety hmm absolutely what about Nancy
that's that's Elena's sister and she
somehow in in her own peculiar ways he
seems to struggle with the related
problem what's house house a Nancy
dealing with that problem he she's the
the wealthy it's not so wealthy logic
for her very opulent upbringing right
but she turns out to be a sort of
impoverished kleptomaniac who can't go
to lots of incredibly expensive shops in
New York she has a special map of New
York because she's not she's taken
things you know which she was going to
pay for later and then never given him
back he's going through but she in her
mind her kleptomania is in completely
justified because she's compensating for
the the wound of disinheritance
says there's an intergenerational flow
of disinheritance Eleanor's and Nancy's
mother married this French Jew can need
to call American money and and the
daughters are left with what would seem
to anyone else
perfectly a lot about it getting a long
way but to them is a devastating my
wound and a devastating loss and Elna
responds by becoming sort of ludicrously
spiritual and pretending she didn't care
she's left the material plane on which
disinheritance takes place altogether
and his only concern was with cosmic
consciousness shamanic empowerment and
so forth she'd lead the Save the
Children fund a favorite charity while
she's failing to save her children and
never mind yeah then become the
transfers small Association has become
even more detached from reality whereas
Nancy takes the other route of being
grossly materialistic grossly
acquisitive grossly nostalgic and and
feeling so wronged that anything she
does to correct the crime and was
committed against her is justified even
if it involves you know ripping off
shopkeepers absolutely Frank you know
getting friends into debt she doesn't
care because she's compensating for an
injustice which is is too great hmm so
yes I mean in that sense all the
characters there is a kind of a
democracy of entrapment in these books
in that everyone is failing to be free
in some way and some people are
grotesquely failing to be free like
Nancy and some people are struggling and
making a little bit of progress but in
one sense all five of these books are
really fueled by that single theme
you know what would it mean to be free
absol and how and how do you go about it
and that's Patrick's obsession and
obviously he's had such an
extraordinarily violent and oppressive
experience with imprisonment that he's
very motivated to find the answer that
he's been imprisoned by his father's
sadism and sexual perversion and then
the prison buyers addiction and he
emerges from that really motivated to
find the answer on that question and and
and he makes a little bit of progress in
him but it take it's slow difficult
torsions difficult room yeah absolutely
honey we're going to revert to that
theme later and what freedom might mean
in these novels what exactly would be
well then ask me I'd just spread the
word around yeah it's like American
presidents freedom this is a freaking
tell you what I what do I think freedom
is I think you've got lots of
philosophers in there thinking about
freedom I look at the most basic level
what I think freedom is is being able to
dispose of your attention voluntarily
you know being able to think about the
thing you want to think about and not to
be distracted by obsession or by
retrospection or my you know projection
just to be able to place your attention
exactly where you choose and I mean if
you think about that it's quite
difficult there is this conversation
between Johnny Hall and Patrick a couple
of times on the difference between
indifference and intact detachment maybe
relate to that
yes I remember that vague I mean make up
nickels read these books in it really
carefully and intelligently very
recently I just wrote them I don't he
did write out a quotation about that
something oh here we are
thank goodness there were passages he
copied out for me which I didn't
remember at all one of the most robbery
I thought was quite good but anyway this
one is I can't I can't imagine any kind
of liberation except eventual
indifference this is Patrick speaking or
detachment said Johnny identify as
you'll ever be indifferent
yes detachment said Patrick you didn't
mind having his vet who didn't mind
having his vocabulary corrected on this
occasion indifference just sounded
cooler and of course he's never
indifferent it's it that you know
Johnny's exactly right indifference is
some kind of you know teenage John Key
idea of what it would mean to be free
the cool of home and and also there's a
debate in some hope about forgiveness
and and attachment and poetry comes to
the conclusion that there's something
slightly patronizing in forgiveness that
the that in order to forgive someone you
have to feel morally superior to them
you know you're you're forgiving them
their crime is against you you're
beneficently setting them free and so
there's that little moral slope as the
slight taint of condescension in
forgiveness relative to detachment and
detachment would be this kind of
transparency this
ability to place your attention where
you choose to and to if you like another
way of looking at it would be to you
know to respond to everything but to
react to nothing you know not to react
to things
hmm but to be free to respond to them
there's a very different forms of
engagement god I'm coming up with all
these definitions of free distinction
you can't stop me now though so some of
the aristocrats in these novels would
very much seem to be at home feeling it
very much at home
sunny grave sense certainly seems to be
manner of master of the house master of
the manor
very much seems to be at home at sheet
Li and yet when Princess Margaret
arrives he is suddenly maybe not as
detached as you ideally might have been
hmm yes Sonny has that he has a sort of
hereditary complacency you know he did
he's um he's born into a position so the
whole problem of self-knowledge is is
circumvented to some extent which which
was you know it has its conveniences it
also has its disadvantages and he needs
a boring bigoted his boring his pompous
you know his wife leaves him he messes
up the dinner with Princess Margaret you
know it's not it's not great honey but
superficially it looks good because
right because of that that all the rest
of us who are born into a position where
our life is defined by by our social
coordinates you know go round wondering
what lives for and who we are and so
forth and to some extent there's he's
being given a provisional answer today
questions but it's not that easy
I mean life would be very dull and he
needs a male era for instance he needs a
fun yeah half alone cheaply mmm that
causes problems as well but in general I
mean yes absolutely so homelessness and
trying to find a home is that there's
something that runs to all of these
novels I thought we might move on to the
to the topic of irony I mean these are I
mean in some sense these are tragic or
bubbles this is this is a tragedy
something horrible happens to Patrick at
the same time these are incredibly funny
witty and amusing novels I know you find
yourself laughing all the time not
sometimes you use novels which is really
quite odd in Denmark a couple years ago
fairly well-known author published a
book about his childhood in which it
suffered horrible abuse it's a very very
serious book there is no humor in that
book whatsoever mmm so I thought it
might be interesting to just briefly
touch on me the the these different
kinds of humor
we've got irony you've got satire you've
got wit and maybe move on to the to the
topic of irony now irony plays into this
part of the sense in which these books
are are very very funny and sometimes
extremely sad as well mm-hmm and and
this is related to to another passage
you might I'm not sure if you want to
read it now sure I don't mind a page for
yes I mean I think I think that the
passage I will read in a moment on on
page 4 is
alright alright but I I agree I'm where
we should definitely read that but it
shows if you like the the the
pathological origins of of Patrick's
relationship with with irony which is
again taken up in in in at last he says
irony is the hardest addiction of all to
give up because it's that desire to be
in two places at the same time it's when
you're being ironic you're saying one
thing and meaning another or meaning
several other things and that that that
business of hedging your bets is
something that goes very very deep in
his psyche so it's it's it's
pathologically rooted but it generates
some humor this is a very short passage
of you relieved to hear he was worn out
by his lifelong need to be in two places
at once in his body and out of his body
on the burden on the curtain Pole in the
vein and in the barrel one eye behind
the eyepatch and one eye looking at the
eyepatch trying to stop observing by
becoming unconscious and then forced to
observe the fringes of unconsciousness
and make darkness visible canceling
every effort but spoiling apathy with
restlessness drawn to puns but rebelled
by the virus of ambiguity inclined to
divide sentences in half pivoting them
on the qualification of a but but
longing to unwind his coiled tongue like
a geckos and catch a distant fly with
unwavering skill desperate to escape the
self subversion of irony and say what he
really meant but really meaning what
only irony could convey
so I think that to some extent if you
like at a rhetorical level this these
books are about this man who's addicted
to R&E in a very profound way because of
these psychological reasons and who
gradually is moving towards being able
to mean one thing you know and in at
last he he reaches the point where he
can he can mean what he says and say
what he means and that doesn't mean that
irony is banished Arnie but irony is
optional it's not it's not unavoidable
not everything needs to be our own eyes
dryer some things can be said just as
they are right and he achieves that
capacity you know in the last book and
that's the the the rhetorical version of
his progress towards a certain kind of
freedom and in turn it touches on the
whole question of inarticulate see you
know of something that that is too awful
to speak of in never mind the taboo of
the rape becomes deeply buried in him he
he confesses it to his friend Johnny in
the third book but the turns out to be
an even deeper level of inarticulate sin
in which which emerges when he goes into
the maternal realm in the last two books
and to begin with mother's milk deals
with inarticulate in a very literal way
there's a Ellen has become Cena and
she's lost the ability to speak
and Thomas has just been born and
doesn't yet have the ability to speak so
one of the central subjects of of
mother's milk is what kind of
consciousness do you have without words
and Patrick is observing this coolly as
someone who's a master of words and is
you know has all sorts of theories about
one kind of consciousness you might have
without words but in at last he's
plunged into his own inarticulately
the fact that he he has a core in him of
something that's never been expressed
and until he confronts that he can't
abandon our aney so in a way there's a
kind of rhetorical or linguistic
reflection of what's going on
emotionally taking place in and
following tracking the question of irony
or inarticulate in this book but there's
another kind of of humor at work here as
well which is very important I think
especially in some hope but also in some
of the other books
name is satire man Patrick is being
extremely satirical and and Nicholas
Pratt one of my favorite minor
characters is also being extremist
Tirico I mean if you've definitely got
the issue of satire yeah and then what
what kind of work does that yield in
these novels well I mean the the novels
I mean to take a step back I agree with
you that basically the core of the
novels are tragic and often the surface
is hilarious and then I think in at last
something happens that takes you beyond
tragedy and comedy and in but right at
the end which we're not going to spoil
by reading but the but in the meantime
yes does
the I suppose I suppose I mean speaking
personally I just see the world as as
you know heartbreaking and ridiculous at
the same time I can't seem to separate
the two you know icon if I were French
I'd tidy it up Moliere taking care of
comedy and rusty in taking over don't we
but it's all muddled up for the English
we come from this this different
tradition I think we're where formality
is less tidy and I just sew it husband
it has many aspects because I think that
whether something is tragic or or comic
is a function of the distance from which
it's seen and as soon as you have
multiple points of view you have you
inevitably have people who are who are
bringing in satirical as well as
heartbreaking perspectives I mean the
wrote yes I mean Nicolas Pratt we could
do something spontaneous I haven't I
haven't you want some Nicholas Pryor
there's pride yeah great okay well this
is so unplanned I don't I don't normally
do this I mean I haven't practiced this
I'll probably mess it up but I have a
feeling he comes into chapter 8 if I can
find chapter 8 in somehow the Princess
Margaret is the key guests at this house
party that Sonny gray Xander's is giving
and Nicholas brought his part of the
inner circle
I'm gonna read this I don't know when
I'm gonna stop so
because well that just hit me on that
actually I actually I got an idea where
I'll stop that
Sony's inner circle the 40 guests who
were dining at GT before the party hung
about in the yellow room unable to sit
down before Princess Margaret chose to
do you believe in God Nicholas asked
Bridget introducing Nicholas Pratt into
the conversation she was having with
Princess Margaret Nicholas rolled his
eyeballs warily as if someone had tried
to revive a tired old piece of scandal
what intrigues me my idea is whether he
still believes in us or have we given
the supreme schoolmaster a nervous
breakdown in any case I think it was one
of the big bets goes who said to a man
of the world the universe as a suburb I
don't like the sound of your friend the
best get Princess Margaret wringing her
nose how can the universe be a suburb
it's too silly what I think he meant
Matt replied Nicholas is that sometimes
the largest questions are the most
trivial because they cannot be answered
while the seemingly trivial ones like
where one sits at dinner he gave this
example while raising his eyebrows at
Bridget or the most fascinating aren't
people funny I don't find where once
it's a dinner fascinating at all like
the princess besides as you know she
went on my sisters the head of the
Church of England and I don't like
listening to atheistic views people
think they're being so clever but it
just shows a lack of humility silence in
Nicholas and Bridget with her
disapproval the princess took a gulp
from her glass of whiskey apparently
it's on the increase
she's heard aromatically what is man
said Nicholas child-abuse said the
princess I was at a concert for the
NSPCC last weekend and they told me it's
on the increase perhaps it's just that
people are more inclined to wash their
dirty linen in public nowadays said
Nicholas frankly I find that tendency
much more while
and all this fuss about child abuse
children probably didn't realize they
were being abused until they had to
watch it on television every night I
believe in America they started suing
their parents for bringing them up badly
really giggle difference
I must tell mommy she'll be fascinated
never start laughing but seriously ma'am
the thing that worries me isn't all this
child abuse but the appalling way that
people spoil their children these days
isn't it dreadful gasps of innocence I
see more and more children with
absolutely no discipline it's
frightening terrifying Nicholas
confirmed but I don't think that the
NSPCC were talking about our world said
the princess generously extending to
Nicholas the circle of light that
radiated from her presence what it
really shows is the emptiness of the
socialist dream they thought that every
problem could be solved by throwing
money at it but it simply isn't true
people may have been poor but they were
happy because they lived in real
communities my mother says that when she
visited the East End during the Blitz
she met more people there with real
dignity than you could hope to find in
the entire core diplomatique
that's a very no reading but hilarious
thank you so much
that was incredibly funny and a very
good example of the kind of satire plays
yes incredibly incredibly funny and I
think a very fascinating to many Danes
because I mean in in Denmark Norway in
Sweden we have a huge amorphous middle
class we don't really have an instructor
see in the sense do you have for not you
how do you K as you can see it's
incredibly funny and also do you know
turns on reveal some of the Britishness
of this fiction I think you would never
get this kind of fiction from any danger
tonight he's just do impossible because
there would be no material less I said
there's a good quote from from Eleanor
and I'm a slightly more serious note on
on this you know wonderful topic of
satire and never mind
chapter 11 American of course is
American and arrived to England and all
of that and and goes like this it's very
brief one so I'll just read it and just
says Ellen is still founded inexplicable
that the best English manners contains
such a high proportion of outright
rudeness and gladiatorial combat oh yes
so what's what's likely to have great
manners the I think that's on the
decline but but it's still a very
visible relative to other countries and
I think what it is is is that in England
because there's there's been in the past
and there continues to be to some extent
such a discouragement of the free
expression of emotion and affection and
so forth there's it's very awkward if
you're not allowed to say you know I
love you I like yours okay so the way
the English show that they like each
others by being incredibly rude to
someone and then if that other person
doesn't punch them or leave the house it
that they're really good friends but you
know there are more direct you could
just say I think people are catching on
they could just say I really like yours
it's taken a while to crack that oh yeah
I mean be Danish I've often felt that
you complete confused in the UK I mean
completely like then you all say you
love each other all the time right but
really I mean you just very I mean I
think we're very direct sometimes but in
a different way
it's very blunt no it's this perpetual
rudeness this rudeness as a form of
familiarity and affection and right you
know it's completely bizarre and very
unpleasant but there is a great thing
about bantering I've really been
fascinated by bantering there's a lot of
bantering going on it's not necessarily
vicious or nasty yes I think that's
that's probably a strong English
tradition perhaps because of I mean this
is fans I'm making this up as I go along
no transfigure but if you look at
Parliament at the Prime Minister's
questioning time it's every used to be
Thursday I think it's now Wednesday the
Prime Minister and the leader of the
Opposition have this gladiatorial
contests and they and they it's a verbal
war between them and it's all about
point-scoring
and and you the Prime Minister goes to
the dispatch what if the leader of the
Opposition stands up he has to sit down
the leader of the Opposition scores a
point to comes back and so the the whole
idea of of debating skills and
of being able to go one better or to
come up with a quick response or so
forth is it's enshrined right at the top
of the system through which we run the
country and it's so oratory is there
very visibly at the top whereas when you
see these I mean they're completely
adversarial the Parliament is is you
know the government and everyone against
the government like that
when you see these lovely horseshoe
Parliament's and people you know which a
spectrums and they have you know right
you have sorry when I see those on Tarot
and there's someone talking it and
there's no one in the room or those or
they're asleep you know they're
listening politely right enlightenment
and they what you want is you know
looking to get some of the drama from
the English Parliament these days go for
it yeah opposite each other in maybe
leads on to another topic I was we
talked about the first time I met you
namely I was I was I was trying to get
you to say something about politics we
just spoken about Parliament's and in a
very obvious way these novels are not
political I mean they're about Patrick
millirems and his particular I mean
challenges and and his way past from
life all of that we've been talking
about that but at the same time there
are many I mean there seems to be an
undercurrent a very very discrete a very
subtle form of undercurrent touching
somehow with gloves on on vaguely
political issues so for instance I mean
there is I mean you talk about maybe the
possibility you reading a very brief
passage or johny on Marxism yeah yeah
I'll do that
okay no I think I mean it is the
there's no doubt about it I mean it did
some there is a critique oh but it's
very much I mean as it should be in a
novel its intertwined with the action
with the thoughts of the character who's
not you know there aren't any kind of
manifesto instantly but but it's there
throughout the the books and in in a
sense another way of looking at what
these books are about or what the
primary crime of David Melrose against
his son is an abuse of power so you know
the books are about the abuse of power
and that radiates to to lots of
different levels and discussion but
without any manifestos but of course
that is a political issue it's
inherently political with a small pea
and takes about a hundred of these
ghosts to precipitate one flickering and
disreputable sense of identity said
battery these are the sort of people who
are on during my childhood hard dull
people who seemed quite sophisticated we
were in fact as ignorant as swans there
the last Marxist Johnny
unexpectedly the last people who
believed that class as a total
explanation long after that doctrine has
been abandoned in Moscow and Peking it
will continue to flourish under the
Marquis of England although most of them
have the courage of a half cotton worm
he continued warming to steam and the
intellectual vigor of dead sheep they
are the true heirs to Marx and Lenin who
better go and tell them said Patrick I
think most of them are expecting to
inherit a bit of Gloucestershire and
stairs pretty funny right she again and
this is so off piste
Miquel doesn't even know I might do this
why don't she I'm not going to do it I
can't find it
but there is another just I do think
very important passage in this book in
last but lost a tiny little thing I'm
going to 162 no no sorry he's thinking
I'm not gonna go too much into the
background of Patrick was concerned as
far as Patrick was concerned the past
was a corpse waiting to be cremated and
although his wish was about to be
granted in the most literal fashion in a
furnace only a few yards from where he
was standing another kind of far was
needed to incinerate the attitudes which
haunted Nancy the psychological impact
of inherited wealth the raging desire to
get rid of it and the raging desire to
hang on to it
the demoralizing effect of already
having what everyone else was
sacrificing their precious lives to
acquire the more or less secret
superiority and the more or less secret
shame of being rich generating their
characteristic disguises the
philanthropy solution the alcoholic
solution the mask of eccentricity the
search for salvation and perfect taste
the defeated the idle and the frivolous
and their opponents the standard bearers
all living in a world that the dense
glitter of alternatives made it hard for
love and work to penetrate so so that's
an a slightly different level of it the
question of money
which I think is is very dominant at the
moment you know we do with the growing
inequality and exactly in America it's
like in England I don't know but whether
here you might have the same thing but
they're just as rich getting richer and
yeah
but working reading horror and people
being stuck trekking nowhere and and
this kind of strange tribe of rootless
super-rich
you know stateless plutocrats II who
seemed to be running running the world
and who think that everything can be
monetized you know that the death of
nature can be turned into a carbon tax
that everything can be reduced to money
which is repulsive but it's very much
what's going on now
anyway let's not get too political but I
just wanted to touch maybe just briefly
touch on Pat for you when he received
the news that his hearse actually
inherited something after all his mother
does this very thing their very best to
disinherit him yes after all he does get
it received news and at last the T does
inherit something little some little
something you might say and and there is
the description of his mixed feelings
and when he leaves the lawyer's office
hmm and they've told him just how little
how much it's actually hairy 2.3 million
dollars a very very minor sum to some
people but not to to Patrick at this
point in time and and this also to this
but there's this reflection on how
random it is I mean Patrick feels that
is so random
honey meter he comes on his mother's
side from one of these sort of American
dynasties and or as you say although the
last two generations have done their
best to disinherit the next generation
there was this kind of time release
pocket of money which left by a great
grandfather or great-great grandfather
you know which just suddenly pops up in
this strange dynastic world but his you
know the passage I just it's lucky I
didn't know you're gonna ask me about
that but I mean the passage I just read
is the background I suppose to what he
feels about it
of that it's it's helpful but he also
feels that there's something shameful
about undeserved good fortune and I
think it is it is demoralizing hmm
I mean in my own life to just forget
personal for a moment I mean I I
inherited money when I was far too young
and I was a heroin addict and I spend it
all on drugs I couldn't wait to get rid
of it you know I hated it I felt ashamed
of having it because my sense of my own
worth was was so low that the idea of my
sort of financial worth being higher or
was somehow in Congress and repellent
and so I destroyed that whereas every
penny I earned from writing my books is
has a totally different quality I do
think that the work is well I mean Freud
said it's work and love that can sustain
a kind you know you you need both and I
discovered work when I ran out of money
it's been the best thing that's ever bit
of money can be quite now sometimes yes
absolutely there would seem to be those
redemptive Liberatore aspects to work
actually having to work definitely
fantastic yeah maybe we should just
briefly talk on identity such a major
theme Yi's works I mean and what what
goes on in the second volume I'm
improvising him I'm just thinking about
Patrick look yeah and and and what goes
on with Patrick sense of identity in in
in the second novel oh my god in New
York he's taken to the road to his 22 is
supposed to pick up his father's ashes
David is finally dead but some really
crazy stuff is going on in terms of his
personality yes and how would you how
would you describe what's going on oh I
would say I would say he's he's in a
state of total civil war half of him is
identified as a as a victim of his
father's cruelty and half of Herman's
done this thing which is famous in
psychoanalysis which was to identify
with the aggressor you know to to
imitate the person who's hurting you in
the hope of appeasing them so he he
hates being his father's victim but he
also hates being like his father and he
has no tools to get out of this trap
because all the tools he might use
contempt
you know loathing and they're all his
father's tools they're all they're all
tainted so he's in a very very untenable
position as RD Laing you know urged us
to call it in there and what why do
people become schizophrenic why do they
fragment because they're in an untenable
position because there's nowhere to go
and they disintegrate under the pressure
and Patrick is he's like a you know a
clay pigeon that's just been shot you
know he's just scatters all over the
place in these fragmentary voices these
compulsory impersonations and he's
filled with other people's words I mean
bad news is the most literary of the
books in the sense that it's full of
explicit allusions to other writers he's
got he's got other people's words
tumbling through him the whole time back
here and and and Tennyson and Djuna
Barnes and Joyce and you know all of
these and uncanny and Conrad and
he can speak in any voice except his own
voice and he he's he's very nearly fully
schizophrenic but it's it's actually
it's just that the thing that just just
keeps him from total insanity is the
fact that he he does the impersonations
instead if he were just hearing the
voices and he fully believed in them as
autonomous authoritative voices but
because he they possess him because he
because of his own theatricality like
there's just a little margin of
creativity he has some relationship with
him he's not just taken over it's a very
close run thing and the middle
originally I was gonna write a trilogy
and the chart of the voices Chapter of
bad news is the middle it's the middle
of the middle the middle of the second
book it's the so structurally when it
was going to be three books this one
rather spoiled by having five it was it
was the point of maximum chaos of
maximum confusion and disintegration and
while there it is I mean I'm not going
to read that that's about 30 feet
actually any person who knows what they
really sound like there are these are
there is a census from the very end
thank goodness Patrick survives the
ordeal in his stage those voices he
comes through that limbo yeah and and
this is wonderful was seen at the very
end of bad news in which he leaves the
hotel that obscene the expensive hotel
heads back for England and forgets his
father's the box with his father's ashes
yeah and then it goes like this
how could he have forgotten the box no
need to call the enna for no
interpretation
I think so there's this constant
recurrence of psychoanalysis and what's
going on with psychoanalysis you refer
to Freud when the decline from session
objects are delaying to my mind as a
reader I mean I get this impression that
on the one hand psychoanalysis is
summoned all the time it's it's referred
to its summoned it's called up onto the
stage at the same time it's often
taunted and ridiculed and puts back I
don't think I don't think psychoanalysis
is particularly I mean Johnny becomes
becomes a psychotherapist and and
Johnny's definitely a benefice I figure
Absalom and he's always you know he's
one he's one step ahead of Patrick and
and in his evolution is understanding of
things but but it's not bought on very
explicitly in the sense that you know I
just I decided I wouldn't write a novel
in which Patrick went to you know 7,000
analytic sessions which carefully
transcribe my fascination it's just I in
it but it's alluded to but I don't I
mean these books don't in any way
endorse a solution and I think that's
important it's important for them to be
you know accessible to everyone and to
be you know neutral in the sense that
the only thing they're really endorsing
is telling the truth you know and I
can't very well avoid endorsing that you
know I mean spend 22 years but but
they're not saying this is how you tell
the truth or this is the kind of truth
you have to tell
except for Seamus Seamus and ridiculous
people from sure I think that sect
mocking things is another question but
I'm not I'm not I'm not endorsing you no
I'm not I'm not there's no product
placement and this but I I agree with
you that the the pressure of a
psychoanalytic worldview is probably
there I hope not
I mean it's there for people but lots of
wait so many things of for people you
can read these books totally
straightforwardly as entertainment or
you can pick up anything absolutely any
number of things I mean that's what a
reading is reading is a collaboration
between the writer and the reader
everyone in this room has a different
frame of reference a different
experience of life and anything they
read will land in a different mind in a
different imagination and they will
build a slightly different book for
themselves and it's a transaction you
know between the the writer and the
reader I really believe that that's very
important and sort of unique to writing
and mattered to me a lot while we were
writing my reading matter to me so much
you know when I was totally isolated
throughout my first 25 years of my life
you know in which I never told anyone
the truth about my childhood
they was reading which reached me which
made me feel connected with another
intelligence and another imagination and
so that arc between the writer and the
reader is a very important thing that I
believe in passionately so I wouldn't
argue with anyone's reading of my books
in the sense you know that they're
making mmm they're making a version of
it in there right
right in their own mind you for instance
are constantly pointing out
Frances which I never meant to write and
III think I told you this is one point
but reading these books actually forced
me to rethink my entire relation to my
own mother
and my own father is actually quite hard
work do you I lied I simply instructed
my mother not to be here tonight what
the burden maze people have won 451 well
I will get to that after no no no no
need to don't dwell on that but I
thought one of the fascinating things
one other fascinating things running
through these novels concerns the
relationship between England and America
there are many transatlantic journeys
throughout the novel's and there is this
interesting exchange of glances the
American glance at England and the
English glance at America as Ellen are
arriving in the UK and there are
Englishmen English people arriving and
America so I thought I mean we're
actually haven't got that much time left
I thought it might be a good idea to if
you read aloud the the passage from
Mother's Milk that we agreed on it
concerns the provide well you know it's
fine that's fine yeah absolutely
well I think I mean I think in in in
simple personal terms that's just to do
with the fact that my mother you know
came on her mother's side from an
American family that had a powerful
effect on my life and we were always
going to America but I think in literary
times its its its Henry James who's a
great absolutely sort of exemplar of
what he called rather possessively my
transatlantic theme
for other people it along I know but I
mean there are tons of feel of you've
got involved but but you're right it's
an Atlantic these books take place in an
Atlantic kind of triangle between
England France and America you know
Hawaii doesn't get a look and there it
is I can't do everything like well okay
this is a little passage where the
family in mother's milk without wanting
to spoil the plot for you anyway they've
lost the house in France and so they
they're going to America in the hope
that's their first family holiday all
their lives they've been to the same
place and as and now they go off to
America and this chapter is told from
the point of view of Robert one of the
sons of one of Patrick's sons who is I
think probably I don't know ten eleven I
can't remember he's that kind of it he's
not he's not yet a teenager but he's an
old child if you like hmm would America
be just like he'd imagined it along with
the rest of the world
Robert had lived under a reign of
American images most of his life perhaps
the place had already been imagined for
him and he wouldn't be able to see
anything at all the first impression
that came his way while the plane was
still on the ground at Heathrow was a
sense of hysterical softness the flow of
passengers out the aisle was blocked by
a red-haired woman sagging at the knees
under her own weight I cannot go there I
cannot get in the air she found him
blender wants me to sit by the window
but I cannot fit in there get in there
Linda said the enormous father as a
family
dad said lender whose size spoke for
itself that that certainly seemed
typical of something that he'd seen
before in London's tourist spots a
special kind of tender American obesity
not the hard one fat of a gourmet was a
juggernaut body of a truck driver that
the apprehensive fad of people who had
decided to become their own airbag
systems in in a dangerous world what if
their bus was hijacked by a psychopath
who hadn't bought any peanuts better
have some now if there was going to be a
terrorist incident why go hungry on top
of everything else
eventually the air eventually the air
bags dented themselves into their seats
Robert had never seen such vague faces
mere sketches on the immensity of their
bodies even the father's relatively
relatively protrude Hrant features
looked like the remnants of a melted
candle as she squeezed into her aisle
seat mrs. airbag turned to the long
queue of obstructed passengers a brown
smudge of hardness radiating from her
faded hazel eyes thank you for your
patience she groaned it's sweet of her
to thank us for something we haven't
given her said Roberts father
perhaps I should thank her for her
agility Roberts mother gave him a
warning look it turned out they were in
the row behind the airbags you're gonna
have to put the armrest up no sorry it's
wrong boys you're gonna have to you're
gonna have to put the armrest on for the
takeoff Linder and his father won't her
mom and me is sharing these seats
giggles under our tushes are expanding
Robert peeped through the gap in the
seats he couldn't see how they were
going to get the armrest on after
meeting the air bags Robert sense of
softness spread everywhere even the
hardness of some of the faces he saw on
the warm and wax the arrival afternoon
in the flags through
mineral crevices of midtown Manhattan
look to him like the embittered softness
of betrayed children who'd been told to
expect everything for those who were
prepared to be consoled there was always
something to eat
a pretzel stall an ice-cream cart a food
delivery service a bowl of nuts on the
counter snack machine down the corridor
he felt the pressure to drift into the
mentality of grazing cattle not just
ordinary cattle but industrialized
cattle neither made to wait nor allowed
to in the oak bar he wants me to go to
you in the oak bar Roberts or Road men
as pale and spongy as mushrooms all
standing on the broad stalks of their
cocky trousers in front of the cigar
cabinet they seem to be playing at being
men they sniggered and whispered like
school boys who were expecting to be
caught out to be made to remove the
cushion they had stuffed onto their past
old button-down shirts and unpeel the
plastic caps there and that made them
look as if they were already bald
watching them made
Robert feel so grown-up he saw an old
the old lady on the next table drape her
powdered lips over the edge of her
cocktail glass and sock the pink liquid
expertly into her mouth she looked like
a camel trying to hide its braces in the
convex reflection of the black ceramic
bowl in the window he saw people come
and go
yellow cab surgeon slip the spinning
wheels of the park carriages approaching
until there grew as small as the wheels
of a wristwatch and disappeared
incredible voices coming that great
actor I think have you ever read this
these passages without in America no
political correctness I'd never read
that before it no no I'll be anywhere
right I think it works Wellington
Margaret sighs thank God I didn't know
when I stood on an American audience I
didn't mind I'm on it the Americans are
better at making fun of themselves than
anyone's face who knows true but this is
very much Robert's gaze at America and
at Americans and Robert is an immensely
intelligent boy hmm which also I mean we
haven't got much time left actually but
just raise baby slight briefly about the
the the role of children as narrators
but at first in Volume one and at first
in in volume four first you've got
Patrick and then you've got Robert when
you see the world through their eyes so
what's when Thomas as well and Thomas as
well actually younger brothers younger
brother that's right yes I I find it
frightening the easy to type into her
childhood perspective I think yeah I've
always felt very tuned in to what
children for this reasons you know what
children are feeling and thinking and
always felt very protective towards them
even you know my worst when I was most
unhappy and
sarcastic and you know a dictate and all
the rest I always I always had for some
reason you know children were exempt and
I because I would say on their side and
so I guess that's that's why it comes
out in my in my writing but I decided I
think the way I've done it is not to do
baby language you know I don't want to I
think it's very important to distinguish
between you know a child perspective
which tries to tell it like the child
would tell it which might be sentimental
cute clawing impressive restrictive and
the narrator the narrator who narrates
everyone's point of view narrating the
point of view the child with a stable
language but with with of course always
the the the needle of dick and always
has to flick her towards the character
who is the center of consciousness of
the time you know people will bring
different vocabularies to to that
situation but still the narration is
even-handed you know it's everyone's
allowed to be I think I want everyone to
be as intelligent as they can be you
know because I think that's more
interesting absolutely for the reader I
read this discussion that was taking
place you met the readers of the
Guardian and in London at some point and
one of the people in the audience said
aren't you I mean projecting to adult
led to much of an idle language unto the
children right and I think that's a very
good reply to that reader right it's
exactly
good hi
I hope he's flown all the way here to
here my arms have formulated Oh two
years
no take what did I say at the time well
you know just very direct yeah we talked
about maybe you ending this session by
by reading aloud from the end of some
hope because you I mean there's there is
this twin set of endings because I
attempt tional everything vol 3 you
can't get another release in the tension
in freedom at the end of volume 5 but in
many ways perhaps the ending it's at the
end of volume threes and its most final
it appears to be the most final but but
those who haven't read it last should
struggle on to the last chapter because
I think the the real ending which is the
last chapter at last is a more profound
release and but this is this is Patrick
moving from a position of complete
imprisonment to the first taste of
another possibility of not being
preoccupied by his past and so it's very
intense for him but then you know
there's more work to do um and so I'll
just read the end of some hope and maybe
we can leave it at heart that you're
after yes I'm not gonna spoil the end of
the whole thing by reading at last I
think or to stop here his thin shoes
grew wet as he crunched across the field
and his feet soon felt cold but with a
compelling and opaque logic of a dream
the late drew him to its Shore as he
stood in front of the reeds which
pierced the first few yards of water
shivering and wondering whether dove his
last cigarette he heard the sound of
beating wings emerging from the others
of the lake a pair of swans rose out of
the fog concentrating its whiteness and
giving its shape the clamor of their
wings muffled by the falling snow like
white gloves on applauding hands vicious
creatures thought Patrick the Swans
indifferent to his thoughts flew over
fields renewed and silenced by the snow
curved back over the shore of the lake
spread their webbed feet and settled
confidently onto the water standing in
the sodden shoes Patrick smoked his last
cigarette
despite his tiredness and the absolute
stillness of the air he felt his soul
which he could only characterize as a
part of his mind that was not dominated
by the need to talk surging and writhing
like a kite longing to be let go without
thinking about it he picked up the dead
branch at his feet and sent it spinning
as far as he could into the dull gray
eye of the lake a faint ripple disturb
the reeds after they're useless journey
the Swans drifted majestically back into
the fog nearer and noisier a group of
gulls circled overhead their squawks
voguing wilder water and wider Shores
Patrick flicked his cigarette into the
snow not quite knowing what had happened
headed back to his car with a strange
feeling of elation
you